pour jouer des matchs il faut d'abord
s'entraîner pour le 15 du Trèfle qui a
choisi tour comme base pour la Coupe du
monde les entraînements se feront au
stade de la chambreerie pour l'occasion
le site et ces infrastructures sont en
pleine rénovation pour un montant de 3
millions et demi d'euros alors les
travaux seront-ils terminés à temps pour
accueillir la meilleure équipe du monde
fin août on vous dévoile où ils en sont
avec Aurélie Renault
les premiers occupants de ces vestiaires
seront les joueurs du 15 du Trèfle les
Irlandais seront accueillis à la
chambreerie dans ce bâtiment flambant
neuf de 1200 mètres carrés d'ici
quelques semaines cette salle sera
dédiée aux appareils de musculation et
parce que l'équipe a de grands besoins
un barnum va prendre place devant le
bâtiment qui va accueillir toutes les
séances vidéo toutes les aspects
statistiques et data sur les adversaires
de l'Irlande sur les forces et
faiblesses et c'est ici que les briefs
et débriefs auront lieu donc sur cette
plateforme qui a été demandé le barnum
sera installé fin août juste avant
l'arrivée des Irlandais et voici le
terrain d'entraînement ton arrosage la
pelouse et scrupuleusement entretenue
par une équipe de quatre personnes le
stade sera entouré de brise-vue afin
d'assurer la tranquillité de l'équipe
d'Irlande le site sera équipé de
vidéosurveillance c'est Monsieur le
Préfet qui nous a demandé vous savez
l'écran événements sportifs coupe du
monde de rugby Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques sont évidemment mis sous
surveillance et un esprit sécuritaire
très important et tout à l'heure on a pu
croiser deux membres du raid qui
venaient superviser visiter prendre les
temps de trajet entre les différents
sites qui vont accueillir nos amis
irlandais
après les Irlandais pour la Coupe du
Monde la chambreerie pourrait accueillir
une autre équipe emblématique pour les
Jeux Olympiques 2024 on parle d'une
équipe outre-Atlantique